So here's what we want to do, we want to go through
all the pages in the graph. So, we'll call them nodes
this time, we can't use page again, because we already used
page up here. So we're going to go through each page in
the graph, giving it the name node. And for each node,
now what we need to do, is check whether that page
links to this one. So we're going to look in graph index
node, that's going to get us the list of all the pages
that node links to. If page is in that
list, well that means that node links to page.
So that means that we should add to newrank,
based on the rank of this node. So that's what
we're going to do. We're going to add to newrank, and
the new value is going to be the old value,
we are summing into the value of newrank. We're going to
multiply by d, that's our damping factor. And, the value
that we're going to use here, is the page rank of
the node. Remember, it's the node that links to this node
that we care about, so we're getting the rank of
the page. What we want to do, is divide that by the
number of outlinks from that page, and that's important,
that means that each, a page with many links, the value
of each link is less. We need to divide that by
the length of that list, which is what we get by
looking at graph index node. So, that's all we need.
We are going to update the newrank. We are going through all
the nodes in the graph. We are finding all the nodes
that link to this one, and we are updating our rank
using the formula to get that. And at the end, we're
returning the ranks. So let's try that in the Python Interpreter.
We have the code that we just wrote for compute_ranks. We're
going to use crawl_web passing in the example site, assigning the outputs
to the variable index, which is the index and
graph. And then we're passing in graph to compute_ranks, storing
the result in the variable ranks. And we can
print out the result in ranks, to see the page
ranks. So, here's what we get. So we get
a dictionary. For each URL that we crawled, we have
an entry where we have the URL, followed by
each page rank as the value. So let's see if
the ranks that we get make sense. So, going
back to our example site, we have the page
Kathleen that has two links going into it. We
have the page Nickel. That has three links going
into it. If we just did simple link counting,
well then, Nickel should be more popular than Kathleen. If
we look at the page ranks, well the page
rank for Nickel is 0.097. The page rank for Kathleen,
is 0.11. So the page rank is actually higher,
for the page that only has two incoming links. And
the reason for that is, well, even though it only
has two incoming links, the links that are coming into
the page, are from popular pages. It's coming in from
the index page, and it's coming in from the very
popular Nickel page. So that's why the page rank of
Kathleen is actually higher than the page rank of Nickel.